when I get emotional no it's just been a
day for me
it's hard
it's like co-parenting it's really
[ __ ] hard Kim Kardashian gets
emotional about co-parenting with her
ex-husband Kanye West
if I'm in a petty Moon
I'll go back and I'll be like okay I
have all the receipts but then I go back
to my babies and I think they'll feel my
energy it's been nearly one month since
Kim finalized her divorce from yay and
during a recent chat on the Angie
Martinez IRL podcast she gets candid
about shielding her kids from the
controversy criticism and negative press
directed at their dad I
definitely protected him and I still
will in my home
my kids don't know anything that goes on
on the outside world I will protect that
to the end of the Earth as long as I can
Kim and Kanye share four children
together nine-year-old daughter North
seven-year-old son Saint four-year-old
daughter Chicago and three-year-old son
Psalm it's a lot and Kanye he's no
stranger to controversy back in October
he shared a string of anti-Semitic
tweets a post that led to his social
media accounts being suspended he later
doubled down ranting even more offensive
thoughts on a since deleted episode of
the drink Champs podcast
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me and while Kim spoke
out at the time on Twitter slamming the
hateful rhetoric and begging yay for it
to come to an immediate end she says at
home she's doing her best to make sure
the kids don't hear about any of it if
they don't know things that are being
said why would I ever bring that energy
to them you know that's like heavy heavy
grown-up [ __ ] that they're not ready to
like deal with I'll do anything yeah to
like
keep their life as normal as possible
Kim explained she monitors what's on TV
at home and she's in touch with their
teachers at school as for social media
she Shields them from that too revealing
North is only allowed to use tick tock
on Kim's phone
[Music]
if we're riding to school and they want
to listen to their dad's music no matter
what we're going through no matter what
is being happening in the world like I
have to have that you know smile on my
face and blast his music and sing along
with my kids and
act like nothing's wrong and back in
October that's exactly what Kim did when
she shared this clip of Chicago and
Psalm belting out their dad's track true
love
shouldn't be this complicated
Kim and Kanye officially settled their
divorce last month they'll share joint
custody of their kids with equal access
though Kim will have the kids majority
of the time and now Kim says a weight's
been lifted I feel free in the sense
that I am not anybody else
I don't hold anyone else's
thoughts opinions burdens
I'm I'm free
[Music]